TIME FOR THE FASTEST-7.
FIRST UP, HARD TO BELIEVE
SITUATION THAT A HIGH SCHOOL IN
NEW HAMPSHIRE.
A LUNCH LADY SAID SHE WAS FIRED
FOR GIVING A STUDENT A FREE
LUNCH WORTH ONLY $8.
SHE WAS ACCUSED OF THEFT BY THE
FOOD VENDOR AND ASKED THE TEEN
TO PAY HIS DEPT THE NEXT DAY.
TWO WORKERS QUIT BUT THE FOOD
WORKER SAID THIS IS UNTRUE.
I LOVE LUNCH LADIES.
>> YOU KNOW WHAT?
I AM GOING TO TAKE AN UNPOPULAR
STANCE.
I DON'T BELIEVE THE STORY.
SHE SHOULD HAVE GOTTEN IN
TROUBLE.
ONLY $8 IS A LOT OF MONEY.
TALK TO ANY BAR OWNER.
THE THING THAT KILLS A BUSINESS
IS PEOPLE GIVING AWAY FREE
BOOZE.
I AM JUST TRYING TO MAKE AN
ARGUMENT.
>> [LAUGHING].
>> IT'S EASY FOR A BARTENDER TO
BE GENEROUS IF HE DOESN'T PAY
FOR THE BOOZE.
SHE WAS GIVING AWAY THE SCHOOL'S
FOOD.
SHOULD BE ARRESTED.
>> LOCK HER UP.
>> AND THE CHILD NEEDS TO GO
AWAY TO SUMMER CAMP.
A FUN CAMP.
>> [LAUGHING].
>> I FEEL FOR HER AND FOR THE
BOY.
IT'S NOT EASY.
YOU ARE BROKE.
WHAT IS INTERESTING, SHE TOOK
THAT RISK.
SHE ALLOWED HIM TO DO THAT.
IF YOU DO THAT, YOU OFTEN DO GET
PAID BACK.
THEY PAID IT BACK THE NEXT.
>> JUAN?
>> WAS IT A MICHELLE OBAMA
LUNCH?
THOSE ARE NOT WORTH $8.
>> I LOVE HOW YOU BROUGHT THE
OBAMAS INTO THIS.
>> [LAUGHING].
>> IS THAT MYSTERY MEAT?
EVERYONE HATE IT.
>> I DON'T KNOW.
I FORGET.
>> [LAUGHING].
>> IT'S A GOOD THING I DIDN'T GO
TO THE CAFETERIA.
I NOTICED TWO OF HER COLLEAGUES
QUIT IN SUPPORT OF HER.
BUT PART OF THE STORY IS THE
FOOD SERVICE HAD A COMPETITOR
COME IN AND WAS LOOKING AT THE
SCHOOL AND WAS WORRIED THAT THE
SCHOOL DISTRICT WOULD GIVE THE
BUSINESS TO THE COMPETITOR.
>> I KNEW THERE WAS ANOTHER
EDGE.
>> THIS IS WHAT WE ARE THESE